uh hello everyone welcome to another
episode of play watch listen
i'm alana i am joined by austin wintery
troy baker and mike
bithell again i'm hungover i'm really
sorry if that shows
oh i wanna i wanna i've never done this
before it looks a little different if
you're watching the video
i can't i can't see everybody and it's
driving me a little batty
it looks like you're poking us right now
yeah exactly i feel like i feel a little
bit intimidating i feel manipulated
yeah yeah i feel like internet issues so
he's on an ipad iphone
right now it no it looks like i'm in
like a 90s music video
you know what i mean oh it does like
yeah
you're not wrong like
you're like the camera doing black and
white from the side
so that we can cut out it's got a bunch
of static overalls
yeah what the uh what the [ __ ] what are
we talking about today
yeah troy you've been real busy all week
uh that's why the episode is late too
sorry everyone
everybody uh i wanted to talk about the
nintendo leaks obviously we're really
late to talking about this but i think
that there's still a lot that we have to
say so
to quote video games chronicle just to
give everyone a recap and a legend
nintendo leak has unearthed early game
prototypes
um this one is like interesting for a
bunch of reasons
it it leaked so much stuff including
uh a bunch of early prototypes from
mario kart and super mario world 2
yoshi's island um wasn't there like
source code and stuff as well like it
was full-on
just tons of stuff uh your source code
for f-zero legend of zelda link to the
past super mario rpgs super mario
all-stars links awakening star fox 2
wild tracks
pokemon diamond and pearl uh first up i
don't understand how this happened
um no idea how this is irrelevant
i mean not really it's just like it just
seems like such a massive security
breach that also i want to like off the
bat
say you know it's been conflicting but
i'm generally not in support of it after
thinking about it more because they're
also like people's personal details and
emails leaked and
yeah it's just it's it's big and it's
bad yeah i didn't realize that it's a
theft right it's a theft
it is that it's yeah which is like sort
of the part that i wanted to talk to you
about
is troy is calling in from the 90s with
a
different opinion of that troy do you
want to jump in yeah back when back when
the opinions on this were probably more
innocent tell us about tony hawk troy
what what's he really like
what's a tony hawk he was popular in the
90s
i mean actually this is where where
troy's
calling in from like mario 64 is the hot
new release so this is that's right yeah
this is very relevant dateline
1990.
there was like a modeled um luigi for
mario 64 that was
in the links as well yeah it's been
rumored for ages that was confirmed so
like you know it's hard to not look at
this and be excited by some of it it's
really cool to find out this information
and while also like being
awful and and like mike said theft but
part of what gets me about it is that
nintendo is so secretive about so much
of what they do that we actually got
information
on how they make things uh for really
the first time
so part of i think i wanted to probably
throw this quest to you mike is like
is the stuff that that other developers
can learn from this
valuable like is it more helpful for
people to have access to this
information than not
i've choked on my own word and by not
sharing more stuff is nintendo like
preventing people from learning um
i don't know i wouldn't i wouldn't say
that they're committing a crime by not
sharing like
sure i'd be a massive hypocrite because
i don't i'm not gonna put my source code
online you know it's not
no one would learn anything from that
though in fairness um
you might learn by counter example
exactly this is how not to make a video
game
no the um yeah it's about it's useful to
see
source code like for sure it's it's
interesting it came up um
a few months ago um ea of all companies
released um
the uh command and conquer source code
uh and already you're seeing a lot of
developers kind of poring over the
client
and this is the original command and
conquer so this is what 20 30 years old
now yeah
95 yeah something wasn't it yeah so yeah
yeah so
in the middle there but like it's like
so it's not like revolutionary but being
able to like
skim through ea put this out there
intentionally for the modding scene
because they're doing the re-release of
the game and genuinely i learned some
stuff just from looking over that and
and to be honest actually more more
looking over the
over the analysis that was being done by
other developers of it because no one's
gonna i'm not gonna sit and read the
full source code but is it yeah
information propagating is useful and
you can often as a game developer you're
kind of trying to reverse engineer other
people's games right because you don't
get to see other people's source code so
mario's jump obviously there's been like
entire research papers on that
but if nintendo released 20 lines of
code they could clear up that up in the
afternoon you know so it's kind of
yes there's value but obviously as you
said like i'm very cautious about like
celebrating what presumably could cost
some people their jobs you know
that's uh that's that you just gave me a
flashback to a
i don't want to take us off course but
there is a funny uh yes you do
you do no no i i swear we're a lot of
episodes
like you're not fooling anyone we don't
it's fine and we love you for it it's
all good
you're you're welcome here i swear i
won't but similarly the idea that like
literally
in one email uh a copy and paste into
the body of a single email nintendo
could
could uh could solve like decades of
speculation
the the the film music equivalent to
that is that there is
endless debate over what time signature
brad fidel's from terminator is in
there is like vicious debate about is it
four four is it seven
eight is it three four as it like this
okay so as someone who knows nothing
about that side of things
that seems like something that wouldn't
be that hard to figure out why is that
not easy to figure out
well because in the score yeah well
because
there's not i got the sheet music back
here we can
yes i'm sure you do um
the short answer is that um
music is written out in a way that is
all about kind of proportionality so
it's like
um kind of like the expression there's
six of one half a dozen of the other
where if you think of half a dozen
of one unit consisting of six sub parts
that's what a half dozen is
versus six is six of one
unit each sure music can be written the
exact same way you know like
notes add up in this kind of pyramid of
proportionality
and so you can write things any dif like
literally infinite numbers of ways
and it's complicated further by the fact
that that was done on a synthesizer so
for all we know
he just played something and it has no
it's not even
like locked to a to a metered out uh
um matrix of of timing it's one of those
that it's hilarious that people there
have been like kind of
scholarly debates about something that
all it would take is
a screenshot uh and it would instantly
uh quell this like 35-year running
i think there's something to be said for
you know not getting access to source
code and not getting access to something
like that
that means that people probably invent
new things by virtue of trying to figure
out how something works
because you don't know exactly there are
other people making things in different
ways which is also beneficial because
then you get more details that also
happens that happens in games all the
time because
the brilliance of games and and i've
made a good career off of this the smoke
and mirror of games is
people assume games are much cleverer
than they are uh it's actually a really
good example of this in the command and
conquer
source code that's been released the ai
for kind of
units pathfinding around the map um you
know back then you know
computer is not so good path finding is
actually a really kind of challenging
thing for computers to do it's very
expensive it can
dip your frame rate and all this kind of
thing one of the many reasons that
having more than five enemies on screen
kills certain games because of
pathfinding um come on and conquer
yield you know ushered in this amazing
era of loads of units running around on
the screen
every other developer saw it and when i
guess they've figured out pathfinding
let's go and do that and the
the did their own games uh command
conquers pathfinding is terrible
absolutely fakes the whole thing they
basically just run in a general
direction they think is you
and they can get lost they can loop
around they can do all of these awful
things
but it yes as you say it's a stepping
stone and if that had been released as
like
this is the easy way we make our ai work
yeah chances are
the other developer would go well it's
good enough no one's complaining about
the ai in command and conquer we'll just
grab that and use that
we all assume each other are doing
cleverest stuff so therefore we
challenge ourselves to a higher level
and you're absolutely right so i was
going to say if everyone was always
releasing their source code do you think
that games would be
advanced or would they just be more
similar like would we have just
grown a bunch or would people just be
making the same [ __ ]
i think that's a really good question i
i think it would be
it'd be great for people entering so
people who are starting out or learning
like to have that research to be able to
just go and
see how things work um it's interesting
that's a really good question i
i equate it to something like gdc like i
think information sharing generally has
a positive outcome like
i'm reading actually i'm reading several
books at the moment but like i'm reading
like design books right now written by
people
so i'll just use the example i've got it
right from here yeah he's pulling a book
out look at him
there you go procedural generation in
game design by tiny short and time adams
oh sorry edited by them and like that is
just basically
each chapter is written by derek you or
you know another person who's doing
procedure generation and they're writing
out kind of their experience
and i can shortcut like i could make
games for 20 years and not learn all the
lessons they can bring to the table with
that stuff
so yeah in theory source code it's good
the the thing with source code though
and this kind of speaks to what austin's
saying is
you do actually need context for it you
do need kind of the scholarly aspects to
unpick
and kind of work that out because you
can't go through all that source code
i'm not going to sit and read zelda
that's hundreds
i imagine tens of thousands if not
hundreds of thousands you're not tanking
the matrix
exactly yeah yeah well no i am i need
someone to point out the red head right
like to use your
matrix analogy like you have to not red
head it's a no it's reference
um like you ty's our resident matrix
expert anyway i'm speaking out of turn
here he's judging you you need
historians you don't know
this is something about sorry go ahead
no it's cool no it's cool i know you
need historians you need academics you
need
people who will filter this stuff and
figure this stuff out
and i'm sure they're already like
archivists going through the nintendo
stuff
um edward snow didn't leak
yeah like it's actually you need to call
through the data but i i wanna it's
something that you said
we're about like learning from this code
with with the with a code with code
that's 20
or 30 years old is it learning like as a
fly to fancy like oh that's cool i
finally have an answer to this question
or do you actually it seems like it
would be so antiquated
based on just the nature of evolving
techniques and technology that
you would look at it and be like oh well
that's cool that has no applicability
though to a modern game
some of it's that yeah some of it's just
being a big fat nerd but i think there's
also stuff that is still applicable like
the the example i always use with people
is that um there's a
i came into the industry in the ps2 era
and i learned you know a bunch of stuff
about kind of
rendering and shading and everything in
ps2 time
immediately irrelevant because the power
of like ps3 ps4 xbox whatever came along
um but then we go into vr and all those
old tricks are really useful again
because all because now we have to hit
performance so we have to be
you know pushing these things forward we
have to be hanging 90 frames a second or
whatever
so all of those old tricks kind of come
back and the same is true i think of a
lot of this stuff the other thing is
is often techniques don't age like
there's definitely like
you know affordances you have by more
powerful computers but like
you would still listen to a piece of
classical music and learn something
about composition wouldn't you like
there's still
there's still it's the thought process
of the composer not necessarily like
the limitations i'm sure if you were a
musician who only worked with
synthesizers you could still learn
something from a piano concerto like
there's still
lessons in there and i think that's
that's very much true of code as well
the part that i also thought about um
that i think
troy you're the you're the inroad on
this one but like the idea of
the idea of like abandoned character
models and like seeing the kind of dirty
laundry
to me it would be the equivalent of like
unfinished
mock-ups of of cues that we threw out i
can think of nothing i would
least rather get shared in the world
than that and it made me wonder like
they must archive every take for example
that you do
for everything uh you know i can start
playing some troy stuff for you if you
like actually
yeah exactly do you have all the
rejected hex takes like
everything's gold everything's gold
everything's gold it would be
well but that i mean you even let's just
say you
uh feel like yes there wasn't a single
take i didn't just
explode enjoy over on hex for example
troy's not you you can't possibly feel
the same way
like there's always i mean i know you
you're always experimenting trying
things saying okay here's the bad
version let's do that
and then see it through it to me it
sounds horrific to think of
that getting out into the world like
that like what if what if there was
you know the the the naughty dog
equivalent of this and there was like a
bunch of joel
uh takes from 10 years ago that were
like still
very early finding it and like it seems
like that would be awful to have out in
the world
it is um how does that happen to you
um never without permission
uh and i think that's that the full
context of
of this there's the amazing if you
haven't seen it the
um uh last of us musical
the last of us musical i have seen that
i mean there is there is that they were
like neil wanted to put that i was like
here's a fun moment we wanted to show
you behind the scenes moments so let's
put that out but let's say that that
leaked before the game
came out um
that would have really changed the
expectations for what we're in for
or it could have destroyed the game yeah
um
and it could have review bombed it and
it was like naughty dogs off their nut
and it was something that was not meant
to be released without context
um when uh
what's his name um i think it was
zuckerberg
um bob zemeckis put out the
you know what you guys deserve to see
this um
here is eric stoltz as marty mcfly and
he put that out to show you context
that that was something that he was like
i feel it's appropriate to share this
with
the rest of you and and the the place
that back to the future has within our
zeitgeist within our culture
is secure that ground is sacred and
preserved we can we can discuss it now
openly
and i'm sure he had a conversation with
eric stultz too going hey are you cool
if i do this
um you too several years ago
um maybe 15 years ago
put out a song called always and it was
fairly familiar sounding and it's dog
[ __ ]
and they said here
is and it's terribly the the lyrics like
always wear your safety vest
always it's awful and they said
that's a very weird time for them god
[Laughter]
oh that's so painful look at him jumping
out there
to his youtube uh i think that's just
amazing i mean that's definitely going
to be the episode right that's going to
go against
no i'm not going to cut it out but i
also like i don't know what he was going
to say about you too
so i actually know the rest of his
anecdote i could tell it but it is it's
the first version of one of their big
songs i can't remember which one it is
he'll tell us where he comes back
oh my god but it's um i just i feel like
it's like it's like the world's most
advanced content id like like
felt it and and they they came
descending down and we're like
whatever smashed in his door came
through the internet and was like you
can't do that
your voice is perfect we gotta cut it
oh hopefully he figures that out that
has actually happened to me once before
in a podcast with troy sadley's having
internet issues it's not been his week
well maybe it has he just been very busy
uh but i guess i sort of wanted to talk
to like
there are definitely things that i've
recorded that i would hate
to have published not because like you
know i've said anything inappropriate or
anything like that but there are things
that have been like
tests that i really hated uh one was
it sucks so badly welcome back uh ign
made me do this sorry we'll get back to
your youtube story in a second we're
gonna we're gonna release that video
troy dude you have no idea the
the freak oh no no no no no the freeze
frame was i kept rolling
i kept rolling and you'll hear me
respond to you please continue
continuing your thoughts uh yeah we were
pitching
a snapchat series for the snapchat
discover pages
and they had me read two versions of a
script and one of the versions of a
script because i feel like i bring this
up story up a lot is stuff that i would
never
say i may have even mentioned it before
on the show where i had to be like hardy
zac
efron is coming to this film this summer
and i [ __ ] hated it i was like you
guys i get that if you green like this
show like that's what you're trying to
do you try to appeal to whatever
snapchat wants but if that's the show
i'm not doing it so why are you even
using me to do that but that like i had
to do a full take that's my job that's
what i had to do
and if that got published without
context that would be mortifying because
that's what i
what i did and i hated it but nobody
would actually know that and they have
i'm sure ign has like a stockpile of
stuff there's uh
when i was gonna get that trending
release it miss it a lot release the
snapchat video
shipping shipping uh alana and zac efron
yeah so bad but also in the moment
the opposite's true as well right that
like in the moment you often don't know
the
historical significance of something
like you don't know
what thing is going to be the thing that
matters it was it's it's um i had a
really good i'm not gonna i won't say
who it was because i
i don't know if they if this story is
like uh
mine to share but talking to someone who
you know a very very big famous
historical figure in the games industry
brag about that it's like active yeah
you have a big famous friends in the
games industry
that was it yeah that was my whole
addict um
but but like basically he was like in
the process of trying to track down
like materials that he just like given
away or sold over the years because
he worked on one of the most arguably
most like historically important games
there was
and was trying to like you know i know i
had this thing and it was
and you know it's it's really
interesting kind of that we can kind of
throw away all of this stuff
and it's uh you know in someone's in
someone's this is why our
archiving and kind of historical context
is so important we
games development you throw away a lot
of stuff you don't save stuff everything
gets deleted everything gets thrown
out there's there's no no record keeping
because none of us are arrogant enough
to assume that this game is going to be
like
the big important thing well which is so
funny
go ahead no go no no go ahead [ __ ] god
damn zoom calls
which is why it's so interesting to me
that uh nintendo apparently
does save everything like i was actually
surprised to see
how much they've archived and i think
one of the main concerns is like if this
much is archived then a lot more
is archived and i just hope that this
doesn't push people to try harder to get
more out of them but hopefully
nintendo's fixed
their security in terms of however the
[ __ ] this happened like i really don't
know how it happened it's
it's a massive terrifying breach
um that's such a bummer i uh what i was
all i was gonna comment on is that it's
hilarious i don't i don't presume
you know historical significance i just
have a lot of german heritage and so for
me it's like there's excel documents
there's all
files are are you know very meticulously
named so that they sort correctly within
the os and like so it's for me you know
finding
finding old files and the correct
version number and whatnot is usually
trivially easy
uh there's just no jobs for it i have i
wish i was like that
i have one thing i keep um so you know
part of working in media is that nothing
that i do is mine
uh it always belongs to whatever company
i'm making it for i don't even
keep i don't get to keep any the minute
that i stopped working at ign they
locked me out of that google drive so i
don't have any of my drafts or anything
that was all on there
um i keep all of the
books that i write previews in so if i'm
doing
uh uh previewing a game i write notes
and i've kept
every single notebook that i've had full
of previews so
and i i don't know why but like you know
if i pull out a recent one this is
is a batman one where i think this one i
think if we've if i've ever previewed
anything to you
we have to go to the notes it's like
baldur's game threes in here
like i just keep all of my notes because
i write them all down like specifically
while i'm playing a game and i just feel
like
those are the only things i've ever kept
that i just i just keep thinking in 10
years when i go back and read
my red dead redemption 2 notes because
they're also not very factual my notes
are like holy [ __ ] this was bonkers like
i'm like very candid in what i say about
them it'll just be very cool to look
back on do you guys have anything like
that that you
intentionally keep i only have it
because kerry keeps it
i had i i threw out all of the thomas
was alone
design docs and everything like post-it
notes
and well she she without me knowing
fished them out the bin and i found
gave them to me a couple of years ago
and said oh this is all the stuff for
that game that turned out to be a
big deal and so that's crazy so yeah i i
throw everything i've
gotten better because i've i guess i'm
just yeah i'm i'm i'm turning into
austin slowly but surely but yeah like
the only reason i have like all of my
notes from thomas alone is
my girlfriend had more faith in my work
than i did
good girlfriend you should keep her
goodbye i i've been meaning to allah
yeah i absolutely have a response to
that but i i
i feel i need i need to get closure on
my youtube story
oh yeah sorry yeah we will circle back
where was the youtube story going
oh it was just that a beauty of what uh
you two did in that was that hey here's
the original
version the first iteration of one of
our biggest songs which would be
beautiful day and the original thing
that they put out was a
[ __ ] thing and they went you know what
we should work on this
and and we can parse out a better song
and they put out um a beautiful day but
then they were like
you know what we want to show you that
we're fallible human beings as well
not everything that we do is perfect and
so they put out
always and i i respect that because i
think there's something
very empowering and
relative when when you say
our first draft is never our best you
know and and that to me can be
like you said a lot is like do you think
it's informational do you think that
nintendo is being withholding by not
allowing the
the industry as a whole to glean
information from them is like hey here's
how we made it
but the truth is that's all proprietary
information that is
100 of the discretion of nintendo so the
fact that it's
out and that we feel that or that
there's a sense i'm not saying we
but there's a sense that oh we deserve
to know this and we should know this and
that we should be discussing i certainly
don't feel that way
yeah well but here's the question
the i i i i'm not sure if this is a fair
comparison but i'm wondering if there's
a comparison
to when all of the um
the leaked photos the nudes of uh
scarlett johansson or whoever went out
um is this similar to that
well i mean i i don't see how you could
make any conceivable argument of
historical value to that so to me
like because there is an academic aspect
like mike was talking about of
like you can genuinely learn from the
leaks of
uh code and and early prototypes and
and like there is a history of
games which is part of the thing i was
going to bring up like if you guys know
chris melacinos
um and this whole like um
the thing that he did with the um uh
smithsonian the the art of video games
and like the idea of creating sort of
like a museum exhibition of the history
of games and and the importance of
chronicling games and all that
to me the leaks as
clearly theft as they are the one little
smidge of gray area is that they do
fill a need that i think the industry
generally is bad
at that i think is valuable and there
should be a better
way of of managing i don't see how there
could possibly be any argument remotely
along those lines with regard to private
i would think they
probably feel similarly violating though
like i would imagine you know that's a
very different thing and it's mortifying
to think about either of those things
happening like my business emails
leaking would be
uh also terrifying as someone taking a
naked photo of me like both of those
would be really bad but i would think
that like yeah it's
it's comparable in that from the outside
i feel like there are a lot of people
who are not talking about
this being a massive violation for
everyone who works at nintendo um and
how that must
actually be for people internally uh
even though
some of them weren't working there at
the time that this stuff was made but
i'm yeah it's still without it's done
without consent which is the
yeah the primary thing is if someone
chooses to share the youtube example
from troy's like that's that is them
deciding to
be awesome and share stuff and that's
cool it should be celebrated but yeah it
should never be done without consent and
right and that's that's a great
disclaimer to put out there and say yes
this is terrible and this is horrible
and clearly should never be done without
consent but let's talk about it let's
get into it and let's say
you know i mean that that to me is is
we we say that to make ourselves feel
better it's true um but
and look i the beauty of this podcast is
that we all have four different
perspectives mine is going to be 100
biased by my own personal experiences
and
i have been guilty of
delving through the salacious goodiness
of
leaked information before but by and
large just as a person who i am
i prefer and my general posture is one
that
i keep my eyes closed before i open my
birthday present
after unwrapping it because i want to
savor
i love the suspense i love how long it
can take for me to experience you know
the the reveal i i i'm a schrodinger fan
through and through
so well but of of the notion of it
exists
you know is it dead i love that yeah
um or alive you know but the
the having having been on this side of
of the and seeing what happens with
a team of you know
500 600 people um
when everything that they have worked
for
um to preserve and protect and carefully
craft
is seemingly undone
by the cavalier
and reckless behavior of a few
individuals
who are ironically known that this will
happen yeah who well
well no they're not no they're not yeah
they're
probably people trying to in the case of
that game trying to do something
negative to
to i think it's an ego thing you're like
well i called out they may like
something yeah they may like something
but they're yeah they're not they're not
fans here's a question for you troy and
i and i really i i don't want to
uh put any any undue light
on what happened with naughty dog but
just out of curiosity if it changes the
thinking
let's say that that happened 20 years
from now like and make it make it much
more comparable to nintendo
uh um it is there is a difference
obviously because
what you have is the success of the
this is the success or failure of that
game
is no longer in jeopardy yeah um
it's also not but it's no less a
violation of private property
it is no less a violation of private
property and
we can't get even get into the the ins
and outs of
how that is how this is so applicable to
old stuff um but
the the you're you're you're
it's fumbling on the one yard line you
know in the fourth quarter of the super
bowl like you
you are you are right there and you've
spent five
years seven years really working on this
thing and you're right there and one
person goes
[ __ ] you yeah and boom and so i look at
that and i go
it's all the same it's it's all the same
if nintendo wants to go you know what
we're going to do the coolest like
anthology
and and we're going to open our
floodgates and look in the vault
and you're not going to believe the [ __ ]
you're going to find that
is a treasure trove that is come into it
it's willy wonka saying come into my
factory
and see how this [ __ ] is made you may
end up like veruca salt
but at the end of the day you'll at
least see how
you'll you'll see the impassioned that
we have and you'll see our failures
and you'll see the our shortcomings and
you'll see
how we became the nintendo of today
but if someone snuck in there with the
camera and was just shooting everything
and caught them all in a meeting and
when they're arguing about stuff and
they're like look at the viciousness of
this company and put that out
or even did that it's like here's a
meeting that happened
25 years ago that for whatever like
you know um like miyamoto like if
if you looked at them it was like i
never saw him in that like that's not
fair
there's no context to it so i
to me the oh well it makes it okay
because we can benefit from it
is not a is not a sound argument because
that is a purely subjective thing
i mean that is like yeah i mean i i
think that that's
that i couldn't more agree
because that's the same argument not to
not to god win this but like
um the one of the things that's always
been fascinating
in a very macabre way is that in the
concentration camps uh
there was a lot of experimentation on
like the thresholds of human pain
tolerance
and and and one of the things that i
learned as a
as someone who has spent an enormous
amount of time underwater as a
as a certified scuba diver one of the
truly uh awful things is that a lot of
what empowers
our knowledge of tolerances of uh
uh for for nitrogen uh
intake uh under pressurized uh breathing
and all that is from
putting humans in chambers and then
basically just seeing what happens if
you just crank it all the way to the top
and then very meticulously taking notes
is as deep as [ __ ] i've never thought
about that before how
benefiting yeah i mean the whole
recreational scuba industry
is drawing a lot of of its data from
the knowledge that was gained there
because like because i mean i know that
nazis did a lot of
a lot of scientific experiments that's
and it's not like that's a conscientious
it's not like that's a conscientious
like
they keep people safe by using that
knowledge that's the grand irony of it
so it's one of those where
you know like this is this is
no one no one could ever ethically green
light those experiments but is it
unethical to not use their results
uh and that's where i don't i don't know
that i don't have an answer to this no
that's [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] intense i also just want
to say i fully agree with you troy um
and it's on me and it's a personal flaw
that i can't help but be excited by
these leaks
but i for the record completely agree
everything you're saying is right i
i i can't turn it off though i'm like oh
my god this information is so cool and
like i should be able to do that but i
just can't like it's just it's just look
at me i i'm the exact same way when all
of those
leaked photos happened i mean it was
i didn't look at any of those and still
have not that i i can draw a line
disgusting i don't want to lie i didn't
either but
there is i i i it's impossible to say as
someone who finds scarlett johansson
attractive go
poof i but then it's like i but the
decision
it's not the thought that makes us
unethical it's the decision
um and and that to me is like i i think
all of us are like i would [ __ ]
love to see what oh my god are you
kidding me to see what an early mario
kart i mean
that that's to to understand the inner
workings of it
and to understand how that especially
for game designers to go there's so much
that i can glean from this
it takes a lot of restraint and it takes
a lot of respect to go
when they're ready to share man that's
great and i think i
i do think the best thing that nintendo
can do is go
let's walk you through this i want to
contextualize all of this
um as opposed to and i have no idea what
their response has been since
i've been yeah
um i did also want to comment on you
know where the last of us leaks were
concerned
uh as media how i would approach that
which is that i did not say anything
about it at all
and uh there are some people in the
community who didn't understand that
like i got a little bit of [ __ ] for not
talking about it my thought where leaks
are concerned
um i think ign's policy is the same and
gamespot's policy is the same
um is if it doesn't actually provide any
service
but to tell you information slightly
earlier than you would have found it out
anyway
there is absolutely no benefit to me to
report on a leak
uh unless or the only benefit would be
clicks
it doesn't help the dev it doesn't help
the publisher and it also doesn't help
gamers
there is no [ __ ] benefit to me
telling you here's the release date of
this game i know it early
all it does is impact someone's
marketing cycle but it's not even like
from the perspective of like oh you're
thinking publisher first
it literally doesn't help anyone to know
that
before they're ready to say it it
doesn't help you to know
the the cutscenes in the last of us part
two it is actually better for you as a
player i would think if you got to
experience that
actually in the game i think that would
give you a better experience
what about this if if you found out
um this is probably a really stupid
question and it's an extremity
of an argument but let's say that the
build that was going to
ship on the game um
and there was no foreseeable patch in
sight
the second that you put that game you
loaded it up it would
fry your playstation just irreparably
damage
and the the developer and the publisher
was like we don't have a solve
right it's that whole argument in fight
club where he says
my job is to go and determine the
probability
of this having it happening again
and if the cost for a recall is greater
we don't do one
we allow we mitigate that loss and we
accept it
so if they hadn't figured out oh [ __ ]
we're going to fry 15 million units
you know or however many copies of this
we sell if someone puts this in there
it's going to irreparably fry and we're
about to do
and they haven't solved that yet and
someone goes i just found out if you
download this game you fry your
playstation
does that change yes that's the least
the service i would report on that
yes and like there are things watch
journalism right yeah
yeah like there are things that i've
leaked that like
there's harm to the public right so
there's a difference between a benefit
to the public and a harm to the public
yeah
i i mean everyone's working in you
anyway but like
so five microsoft employees told me
that fable was in development five of
them and when it was the first two i was
like
cool like i know you guys are sharing
this because you know i love fable and
i'll be excited about it
and then another one did and then
another one did and then another one did
and i was like
okay and i ended up saying it on i think
i did it on a kind of funny show i was
like
i know fable's being made microsoft kept
telling me but i actually
now regret doing that it's it
to me it felt like a like there's so
[ __ ] many of them told me that it
feels like they want that like
you can't have five of you do like this
what are you doing
because they just kept [ __ ] telling
me but then when i when i saw the reveal
uh i was i was still super excited
because i just wanted i didn't know that
it was going to be in that conference
so i was still very happy to see it
because it being in that conference
meant to me that it was maybe earlier
than i expected or whatever
but uh i wish i hadn't known and thus i
wish i had not told anyone else
because i would have been way more
excited if i hadn't known um and i guess
part of that was that they didn't have a
very good lid on it anyway
like i feel like i maybe sort of sub
tweet about that mike because like
everyone knew that game was being made
in any case but it's still a thing that
i was like
wish i hadn't done that well here it was
because just the british games industry
right it's too chatty in general like it
was just a known thing but even then
like i wasn't going on twitter and
i i i said a thing that people who knew
what it was would know but i didn't yeah
i would never ruin someone else's reveal
that's
yeah thankfully i didn't ruin the review
when i did say i knew the game was in
development i didn't know it was playing
around i didn't say that but i still
feel like
i shouldn't have done it uh it just it
just got to a point where i felt like
they had told me so many times that i
was like for [ __ ] sake like you guys
are being so dumb
i don't know what i'm even supposed to
do but i shouldn't have done there is a
there is a difference right like some of
the stuff like yes definitely like
spoiling something or revealing
something earlier than like
the best most fun way of that coming out
yeah i i
i don't think the role of the press is
to ruin surprises
but there is also the other stuff which
is
you know if if bad practice is happening
behind the scenes absolutely if
someone's being troy you just use the
example of like
shigeru is an awful person who's yelling
at people in boardrooms i'm sure that's
not true but if that were the case
i think there is a a very valid case to
that being public information and being
something that is
it provides a service to the public but
some of that stuff do you think no i
think there's a responsibility because
by that argument if we stick to that
argument of providing a service to the
public then
what about you know if we're trying to
you know oust
off predators right which is something
right
there's no service to the public in
knowing that
ubersoft has loads of horrible people in
it that doesn't serve the public
but it is the role of journalists to
kind of check yeah yeah
yeah but but mike if it was this
like miyamoto-san is is a bad boss
and he curates this is this is all i'm
i'm using him as an example this is made
up because we're
using this example
[Laughter]
so it is and we could even bring it more
um
there's there's bring it to naughty dog
where
it's like they they did this and this is
the the culture that they curate
and somebody walking through on a day
had that perspective and run ran an
article
and now it is it was chipping away
and especially in that moment when it
was happening was just
gasoline on the flame of dissension um
of people that were already tired and
exhausted but
willingly working towards something that
they wanted to work for and
also discussing a topic that naughty dog
was like yeah man we we want to fix this
this is not
a good thing we want to do better we
want to make better games we want to be
a better studio
so they they oh yeah everything on their
face
i don't think troy i think that one's
going to have to be a a disagreement
between us like
because it's incontrovertible hold on
hold on hold on
and with respect to any company by the
time a journalist
like is hearing about crunch crunch has
existed for a long time that
the companies have the opportunity to
fix that problem
okay but how can you how can you
disagree with the fact that a studio
says
we are wanting to do better there's you
put that in the article
you put that in the article you have the
i mean i can illuminate like specifics
of how this works but like you give them
the right to reply but you still tell
the story
this is my biggest criticism of that
naughty dog story is that
every single friend that i have that
works at that studio which is like a
pretty significant number of people a
bunch of aussies like quite a lot of
them
uh all i'm not knocking naughty dog in
particular by the way it's just a good
example
they all felt that that article was
shaming them for
things they were proud of doing and yes
that's very complicated where crunch is
concerned because that's a culture of
pressure that you are tricked into
thinking is something that you should
want to do
very very complicated psychologically
but it felt like unfair reporting in my
opinion that it was
that that that coverage was only and
intentionally only
highlighting the negative side of
something rather than also going through
the effort to talk to people who felt
opposite in the studio which from what i
can tell
is literally all of them is a lot of
them yeah okay
so in which case i've not read the
article so yeah i would i would expect
that balance but i would still expect
the story to be published
right just with with more of the
dissenting
that's the beauty of journalism is that
anything can be published
right you know what i mean like there
there is freedom of press so we have the
ability to
say something what i'm talking about is
being responsible about it but the
you you can say whatever you want but
the problem especially within our
culture right now
is that there is zero
like we've talked about before alana you
said there is an assumption
that it is the responsibility of the
general public to educate themselves
and we are using this piece this article
this
whatever to help inform them but it's
still the onus is on you
to go now go find out some other piece
of information before you film your
opinion on that
we completely lost that so it's like did
you hear this this is what this person
now it
now believes fundamentally so it's like
man miyamoto had a really bad day what's
that oh he got mad at somebody in
a conference call or whatever he's like
what happens like i just heard him raise
his voice so miyamoto yells at people
yeah miyamoto yells
he yells at everybody and then there
miyamoto's got a gun you know it's like
it just
telephones out but
there's none of them no garden
there's a theoretical garden
but what i'm saying is is like even if
that were
true that he had a bad day even if it
were true that he yelled at somebody
even if it were true that he did that on
a conference call
there is still no threat to the general
public
to go now we need to oust him it's like
no
that is the company no but a journalist
could investigate that story that's
that's the kind of they they would find
out
you know they talk to some of his
colleagues they'd go in again
moto lovely guy from everything i've
heard they'd go in they'd investigate
they'd try and find out like what that
was all about
and then if they thought there was a
story there they'd report it there are
also
benefits to people who might have
interest in working at nintendo i to
know that
and the people currently working at
nintendo yeah like
the games press the games press also
works for people who work in games
at the ground floor people who who who
need you know
the help of a press who's gonna check in
on their bosses and make sure that the
companies are being run well
that's a good that's a good natural
thing we we want people to be paying
attention in that way
because it means that they catch the
actual genuine awful monsters
that's my view yeah i was at uh right
after
right after journey came out um it it
ends with this
uh song more or less called i was born
for this that's
sung in five different languages and
there was nowhere to find what the
lyrics are and what language what they
translate to
because i wanted to write like a blog
post you know to kind of unpack it
because it was a lot of work and it was
kind of a cool story and i just hadn't
had time yet
and so it was like a week or two later i
was out somewhere and someone
at an event and someone comes up to me
and they go can you tell me what the
lyrics are it's really you know
interesting and
and i was like and i had been getting
hammered with tweets and messages from
people saying can you say what this is
can you
can you translate and i was like just
give me a minute just give me a minute
and
i was really surprised there was this
much interest and uh and so this
this young kid basically comes up to me
they're probably 18 19.
they come up to me and they're like can
you can you like i saw that you don't
want to share but like
you can tell me and i was like honestly
i just need to i said
i just want to gather my thoughts
because there's there's a lot to it like
it's
and i'm not fluent in these five
languages and i'll screw it up and
and you know so it's like i i just you
know i said it's funny
i didn't think people would care this
much and it's it's been almost
funny to see it's like torturing people
but i i really am just shocked that
people care that much
[ __ ] five minutes later a blog goes
up austin enjoys torturing people
and i was like what and it was like if
you read if you read what they wrote
they were like oh i just met him at this
event earlier
this week or whatever and it was not
explicitly trying to kind of attack me
but there was al there was definitely a
click baby like
he he's holding something and enjoying
how much people are going crazy for it
and i was like
hold on here yeah like and
no harm was done i'm not nowhere near
important enough for any of it to have
mattered but it was one of those things
that i was like holy [ __ ] a joke
like tone of voice being removed
just from that because they were they
were not inaccurately quoting me
but like you you remove one crucial part
of it and instantly i was like man and i
feel like
thank god that was back in 2012 uh back
when we were young and innocent and
and things didn't move so fast as they
do now
uh because uh yeah anyway it was one of
those one of those few moments where i
was like man
extrapolating this by several orders of
magnitude
is what makes me realize you know
high profile political figures or famous
actors and directors and like
with the slightest wrong thing and it
and it can be not wrong
it can be just wrong through the super
subjective or agenda-driven view of
someone in that moment
um man can that be repurposed so yeah
that's why i feel like yeah your
miyamoto conference call story is a
really good example
that there was actually even in your
playstation you're you're
frying playstations uh hypothetical also
there's a whole thread about there's
like a whole story thread about that
towards the end of the american office
where their
their saber printers catch fire and they
decide to take it upon themselves to be
whistleblowers and they do
massive [ __ ] damage to the company
because the company already knew it and
already had a fix underway
but they thought they were being these
yep super badass whistleblowers exposing
the truth
and they actually did made things way
worse so it's like
hmm i mean i i really do think
you'll question that mike of like are we
benefiting the public by outing bad
people
is ultimately my answer would be is that
it i think it's subjective
and on a case-by-case basis more case by
case i think the case-by-case is
essential
like i don't i think yeah
yeah there are absolutely reasons that
things should be reported on and
it because because journalism isn't
always about benefiting the public it is
also just about providing information
and my thing with with release dates or
right my thing with release dates or or
titles being in development being
confirmed is that
all it does is give you something
earlier than you are already going to
get it anyway
you know and like i had a conversation
with a journalist not that long ago who
was talking to me about like after i
posted a thing about ign reviews and he
messaged me and was like well ign won't
let me publish this massive leak because
they care about the publisher like there
is an ethics problem here they're just
trying to save the publishers like i
promise you that's not why ign isn't
publishing that leak it's
it's again because all you would be
doing is saying something two weeks
before they would be saying it
like it's that you're not providing
information people aren't gonna get like
there's just
and it's also again with release dates
especially if i'm giving you a release
date early
that release date could change by the
time they want to give it to you and
that's happened to me like i was told
by sony bend the last of us part two was
definitely coming out
the same year as their game those days
gone they told me that at e3
and i was like i ended up candidly
bringing it up once that i was like yeah
they 100 said that to me
by the time the game count it wasn't
true so what's the point in reporting on
it if like
yeah they said that to my face it wasn't
nda and i didn't sign anything they
candidly were like well you know we are
coming out in the same year but it'll be
several months apart
if it doesn't end up being that way
what's the point in reporting at least
delicious clicks alana you need
that's it the whole the only service
that you provide i think
for people who are like very in on like
trying really hard as journalists to
leak that kind of information is clicks
and i think in some cases they want to
feel
cool they just want to be there we
there are shades of grey here there are
dif there is a difference between
releasing information about a product's
release
and information that actually serves i'm
being very specific
in uh in it being
i think i would fall on the line of i
think the
the naughty dog culture expose
is something that um is worth reporting
on
uh but i do think it should have been
done more thoroughly
um because from what i can tell even
just candidly talking to friends at that
studio who were open to talking to me
uh
if someone's brought into a place and
let's say i went into it's like welcome
to the sausage factory you want to take
the tours like yeah i'm going to take
the nickel tour
and i take the nickel tour and the
purpose of me being there is they invite
me in so that they can show me some
things
and then i go out and i write an expose
because i wandered off the tour
and i overheard things and saw things
that to me
is that's not good investigative
journalism
isn't that literally investigative
journalism
it would actually depend on what you did
but if you're recording
conversations that are privately held
when you've been asked on a
tour as a journalist i don't think you
are technically allowed to do that
without consent
it's like it's like illegally obtained
evidenced by the police can't be entered
into court for the same reason
so yeah like if you bust into someone's
house without a warrant and see that
they have drugs
and you're trying to get them on another
chart they may have drugs
yeah you that like that and i believe
that's a very important principle for
what it's worth
yeah i just think that if someone's like
if if someone brought in is like yeah we
you know um game inform or whatever
wants to come in is like let's do an
article
and the the the it's under the
auspice and the guise of like we're
gonna do this but then it ends up
becoming something else
um i just i feel like it's
you know if you are if you're
i'm unwinding this argument as i go but
if you came into my office and we were
gonna sit down and
in the midst of it you you saw me
demonstrating behavior
then that's going to influence your your
article i i understand that
um i just don't think it was like come
on let's talk about the last of us i was
like okay let's talk about the last of
us and then you do this like here's this
cutthroat
you know re you know expose like you
said
is that the naughty dog culture well no
one's going to come and say do you mind
if i do a uh
investigative journalism piece on your
culture as a studio
in the middle of i assume that the
developers reached out to the
journalists involved is that
not how this worked i assumed it was
developers who were complaining about
the working conditions
no because there was somebody there
there was it was it was the
criminal just walked into the cafeteria
and listened in
they were they were there to they were a
journalist you know they were
they weren't someone that was that was
just hey i want to let you know i this
is what happened
they were there wait and reported this
but it was jason wasn't it
yeah jason went to the studio and then
as i understood it
man i don't want to get mired in in the
sure but here here's a great example
well just as a takeaway as a summary on
that thought i do think that you
are right to the degree that if someone
has a very
narrow snapshot of a place
and makes a sweeping especially a
chastising
um summary of it based on you know
such a narrow perspective uh
i mean i guess you kind of have already
said this a lot at minimum
they should allow naughty dog the
opportunity to weigh in and respond
because i just
from my you have to get more sources
it's about journalism if you don't
it's not bad journalism to be like i saw
this and i want to pursue more
information about it it's bad journalism
to see
to say i saw this so i'm going to report
on this and i'm not going to explore
anything else
would you go to them and would you be
like hey i want to let you know this is
the article we're going to run with
i've done that anytime i've given
something a negative review even i've
been like hey
like i uh when i reviewed uh
levels within which is ubisoft's
basically just werewolf
psvr game at the time it was buggy as
hell
like you know sometimes the book that
you need to see all the notes wouldn't
load in and you'd have to like leave the
match and go back in like
it just had tons of bugs i told ubisoft
i was like this is really buggy i
i need to review this like is there any
chance that you guys will be fixing this
in like the next five days because i
need to get this review up
i gave them a little bit to respond and
they ultimately were like no we can't
i was like okay i have to publish this
negative review i g but i gave him the
heads up it was like this this is broken
and it sucks but
i did tell them that and i've done that
for every negative review that i've
written i've been like
here are the issues are there any chance
the issues are being fixed because then
you know my review would also be dated
for the public too
um but it's giving them a heads up and i
would also like
by virtue of having asked the questions
potentially have a roadmap that i could
supply in that review about
maybe this is is going to be fixed in a
month because the public should know
that too if i'm telling them something
negative about something
uh if i were to give yeah if i were to
write a negative story about something i
would
always tell them or ask for comment
probably both in the same email i think
that's pretty steep do you feel that by
and large that's kind of like standard
you know standard practice for for most
people or do you feel like there's like
now there's two camps that like
will do that and those that will not
yeah i think that depends on the
on the journalist but i think that like
most of the major outlets would
absolutely encourage you to do that
seems like this is also just
systemically a big challenge of
a kind of twitter length headline length
consumption culture because it's
something that stops the scroll
right yeah yeah like it like for me
crunch is a
really really nuanced subject because i
know lots of folks i love mike's
eyebrows every time someone uses the
word crunching because it just it just
goes from this and goes
i appreciate his anti-crunch stance yeah
i do too so do the people who work for
me
the thing is i've talked to developers
before
that put in very strict mechanisms
to stop crunch and then the team
complained
like that where they said things like
you can't work after six o'clock on a
friday and people were like what the
[ __ ] that that's what that's my golden
hour man
like don't don't micromanage me to that
degree like i've i've i've
had conversations there are ways like
that's that's that's an example of
something that there are ways around so
i have team members for example who will
clock in at like midday because their
their time but it's the hours spent is
the thing you're trying but what if i
want to
but what if i want to work like i'm not
ashamed to admit that the last few weeks
on the path list there's no way i've
worked less than 90 hours a week not a
chance
yeah right i'm not getting paid one
extra penny for that and i harbor zero
grudges over that fact
so it's like but it's also a team of one
right you are a team of one you're a
team
exactly you're you're you own a company
there will be different if you are
making
other people underneath you work the
same and you're
musically you're someone in your
position you're not the lowest rung on
the ladder are you
no yeah i have a question though but
that makes it great right like because
because you you can i work i work long
hours but i get to own a company that's
the trade-off yes
it's a very different thing yeah if if
if you
if you had a person on your team
that everyone else was just like by the
numbers and
this is a this is the person that is
like critical what they do is they
always deliver and your street date was
x you needed to go gold by september 1st
and that person was like um
i'm not gonna be able to get this done
because in order for me to do my job
and and the the practices that i have
and and it just takes too long
you're gonna have to push what would you
do
you've got a million options so i've
been in that situation count
yes you do yeah you do you so i've been
in that situation i love knowing this
okay so
in education okay so so this is a little
genuinely
leak no there's a few no no like
definitely but it's consensual
there's no there's no game company in
history who's not had like a tight
deadline right
there are loads of solutions first one
is if that person thinks their work's
due in september probably it's actually
due in october november because we
always build buffer into all of our
timelines so whenever
anyone who's working we have an absolute
kind of buffer structure
that means that that person has some
buffer they don't even know about
just for that very occurring so i can
say in that meeting it's cool
it's up close but you've got an extra
month and you think you have please do
it
that's the first line of defense if
that's
not work
[Laughter]
well it's not lying it's it's it's
project management like to an extent
like you build buffers into project
management when you're when you're
working on i love that that's so
orwellian it's not lying it's project
management you're like
you're george costanza it's not a lie
it's a varying dispensation of morality
if that's not worked if they've gone
over still or the task is still
way too massive that's when you have a
conversation either with your
partners about moving the street date
which i've definitely had to do in the
past
or you've changed scope and you say okay
well we're not going to do that then
and you make those those tough choices
and that's and that is
that is my job my job is not to say
we're going to make the perfect game
and screw everyone who works for me
we're going to work long days if we need
to
my job is to look after my team and look
after the people who've paid me
and do you feel like the people who pay
me know that they're second in the queue
and that's let's say that's what's
getting very cruel no no i love this
this is
and i love that this is one of the i
love where this podcast has gone to by
the way
not not just this as a whole
but if let's say you have five people
look there's th
this to me crunch to me and this is from
my
adjacent not naive but definitely
uninformed not not even uninformed but
um
less informed perspective because i do
believe i'm not just the average joe
walker on the street i i i know
enough about the how the industry
operates
but to me it's the kobayashi meru right
it is it
crunch is not about success it is about
mitigating failure
um the
if you have five people and all four of
those people have worked on this one
thing and the one person
is going to be like i can't do this and
you go okay you know what you've got an
extra month or
to use your examples like then we scope
we're actually going to cut this
those four other people that did pull
their own weight
now you're talking about you know
you jumped into immediately like a very
specific thing away you said the four
people have pulled their weight
and that fifth person has let you down
that's an enormous assumption
like in terms of how projects work out
maybe i gave that fifth person way too
much to work on maybe i didn't do a good
enough job of checking in on that person
because at the point where the person's
going
i can't do this i need to crunch they've
probably been struggling for months
they've probably been stressed out
they've probably been coming to the
office tired they've probably
having more fights with their loved ones
like you can check in on this stuff and
you can have review processes
we check in on our team we have a i have
a call with every single person who
works for me every month
checking in on them how are you doing
where's where's the challenges who
you're not getting on with at the moment
how can we help with that how can we
help this process
every two weeks we have we have sprint
meetings which again are pretty common
in the tech sector
not in games industry we're a little bit
looser with it but we we check in on
people we say
are you achieving what you said you'd
achieve in these two weeks no
okay no judgment but but why is that is
that we've given you too much is it that
something happened in your personal life
that distracted you like why
how do we plan so the next two weeks we
actually hit the line
and if you're doing that throughout it's
it's like
you know if you it's like saying a
budget like for your month right
if you're if you're running out of money
in week three of a month
that's because you made bad choices in
those three weeks leading up to that
month
it's no and
it's basic producing and project
management and unfortunately in our
industry
and this is not a specific statement
about any individual
in our industry if you're very good at
coding you get promoted into
managing coders and those are two very
very specifically different
exact same things yeah same
same here yeah people who've been in
media for a long time get promoted to be
managed
there are people running mcdonald's who
are more competent
producers than many many people i've
i've worked with in the games industry
it's because if you're in the mcdonald's
the burger has to be on the plate and
the dude has to show up to work
you know at a relatively low wage the
next day so you have to be
competent what you're doing and the
games
i agree with you look first of all
no marriage ever broke up over one
get it babies preach no marriage ever
ended a divorce over one fight
exactly what i mean exactly it is no
relationship ever ended because of
one argument um and i i definitely
believe like
there's a lot of i haven't had this
conversation this week where it's like a
lot of actors want to become directors
they don't want to become directors they
want to be in charge and they want to
somehow
undo all of the the violations and
atrocities that were
imparted upon them throughout their
career and somehow
you know uh a tone for for either their
sins or the sins of the others through
those actions
that's not being a director and one of
the person i was talking to today was
like directing
you know 80 of directing is meetings
and it's having a meeting about this
thing is like and then every once in a
while i get to go to set and work with
actors
and i was like that's a very important
thing
to and even neil talks about this about
two hours a day
like about two hours a day where i'm
able to do what i think most people
think my job probably is and the rest of
the days
there's this just made up of meetings
meetings and zooms and emails and and
whatnot
um that's why we ship on time and on
budget and we don't do crunch because
we're paying attention to that stuff and
it's not just me it's i have amazing
project managers and producers around me
as well it's worth
it's worth saying that you know that
like i'm one of a team of people who do
this stuff and
unfortunately they're all much better
than me it is it is worth noting
mike that i for my or austin you said
this as well like the reason why we give
you shiz because we love you
there is i just get a little bit of
passionate about that stuff
i'm sorry i know and and that's
i don't feel you're aggressive at all i
also feel like um
us being able to get into it is
is a sign of respect not only just for
you but also for each other that we can
all have this conversation
and this to me is is what
talking about benefiting from
information i know more than i did when
we started
so if this is the beauty of discourse
this is the point of discourse is to be
able to
have a different perspective be in
opposition to each other and by the end
of it's the whole reason why i have this
tattoo it's like let's get to the
solution as quickly as possible
but your perspective plus my perspective
equals a better perspective for
everybody
um it's not about come win i want you to
come over to my side it's like
can you and i find a new side together
yeah so
i think uh one of the one of the little
points that you made
um um
mike talking about one of the solutions
we've been doing the show for a while
austin
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're all very good friends we're all
very
the point that you made that i think is
also worth highlighting about
one of the solutions in your toolbox in
that instance that troy was laying out
is scoping um just coming from a
personal angle to kind of reaffirm that
because i tend to be the bullish type
that someone says look
you know we've added this cut scene and
maybe there's a way to just take some
existing music
and and refashion it so that you don't
have to write five
whole minutes extra by tomorrow and i
tend to be the kind of type that's like
but it deserves something new i want to
get i don't care if i'm up till five in
the morning
like bla and like to my own health
detriment sometimes to the detriment of
relationships 100
yeah yeah like those drunk streams
aren't going to make it
as well to be honest and uh but i would
i would never do that to anybody else
though i wouldn't know no no no no
that's it no no i'm not that's not the
plan i'm making
i completely agree i completely agree
and i've had people
working for me before i've had some
i've had people working for me before
that later told me
that like they were that they were
basically working
not just long hours but that they were
forging through some actually
stories that i i won't share even in a
vague way but like very personal stuff
that
they in no way should have been feeling
like they were juggling and i said
did anything about my management style
make you think that you had no choice
here
because i would absolutely have found
someone else to cover you
and it would have never threatened your
prospects of our collaborating again
like
you i want you to have the space to go
through it and they said they said
actually in my case
it was the work was the catharsis that i
needed or was like the
not even catharsis it wasn't catharsis
but it was like the distraction i needed
for that short term
because i knew the job was only going to
be another couple more days and then i
was going to be able to take that time
and it helped me get through the shock
of that thing it's worth adding it's
worth adding one thing to what you said
though austin in terms of like i think
and this is this is true of so many
things in life we have to be actively
good
we can't just not force people to work
crunch we actually have to completely
agree or
force people to we'll go over we have to
actively it's uh you know
actively make it very clear that the
question you asked of what did i do to
make you think that that was what i
wanted
we all have to explicitly say we don't
want it yeah and it's a running joke in
my computer
i see you on that computer at 7 00 pm is
yeah if you're working until 9 00 pm
mike
and you're saying i don't want any of
you to crunch but the other people
in your studio go oh but the boss works
until nine pm
i should do that too
i think and i think that like it is it
100 is i did have to
one time my solution was one of the
executive editors at ign because like i
was already working absurd
hours i went like six weeks without a
single day off like constant travel like
i already was and there was one point
where one of the executive editors was
doing the same thing but bragging about
it and i was like
you doing this a is bad means that i
have to do it more
b means that everyone under you is going
to feel like
if i want to be an executive editor like
him one day i have to do that too
i get that you're like proud of yourself
for how much you work
but that is perpetuating a culture on
every single junior member of the team
that they have to be like you
and they don't necessarily the people
who can handle it in the way that you
can handle it or
they don't want to and you do and you
and you have to explicitly stay there so
i
i was called out by a team member once
about this and they were like you you
work
the key thing which we did actually and
we we immediately solved about this or
not solved you're always trying to make
things better you're not solving things
was was specifically it was made very
clear to everyone in the company
mike works late because mike's making
mistakes or if it's a [ __ ] up
and my team knows that the way to a
promotion is not
to work long hours explicitly like
explicitly
you we judge you on how you manage your
time mike [ __ ] up
might get stoned the company and
therefore obviously profits a lot more
from our projects long term than
the individuals who work because yeah
capitalism
so so you're right it does need to be
addressed it's something though that you
have to always be on the lookout for and
i actually did cut down my hours a lot
when i started hiring people because it
was something that kept coming up and
that was the the best solution was just
to kind of trim that down but you're
right like the
i'm definitely not presenting myself as
a saint on all this there's always work
we can be doing to improve this stuff
for sure
there's two things that i want to add on
to that as well number one i
to to counter my previous argument um
the director that i worked with this
week very very beginning he
sat us all down we were able to we're
all super grateful that we're able to
shoot again because we
went through such rigorous covet
compliance but he said good morning
everybody
uh by the end of today you will be tired
so will i
and all i ask is that you keep up with
me that to me is good leadership because
it's like
i'm not asking you to do anything i'm
not willing to do myself the task that
is set before us is
hard know that i will not be in front of
you i will be beside you and if
sometimes i'll be behind you pushing you
i think that is it's like look
making a thing is hard so if you're
expecting this to be easy
then that's this is not what you need to
do it's not my job is not to make your
job
easier my job is to help lighten the
load so that we can all do a hard thing
together
so i i do think that there is a fair
balance between
not going oh i'm sorry is this is this
difficult well let's let's put feather
down pillows all around you it's like no
dude
this is a hard thing to do but but
that's not what crunch is to be very
clear like no no no no no no
i'm not i'm not saying you work hard but
you work hard within the hours right
allotted and you also don't ex
you have to like you said you have to be
able to um
look at that you're going i'm not gonna
let you go in the red all right
you're gonna you're gonna rev up this
engine has to go to this in order to get
to the speed that we need
um but i'm not i'm not gonna make sure
he's like i know he's in the red i know
he's in the red
um there's the the whole scene in in
deep impact where robert duvall is the
pilot
and she says you gotta you have to shut
down the engines now we've calculated
this exactly like they always put in a
little bit more she goes shut it down
now
so there there is a point where you like
i i i have to operate within the
parameters and hope for the best
somewhere right now movie leader is like
my film just got
my 1997 uh better than armageddon
oh for sure
is that there was there was this whole
uh situation within sag as far as like
look what they make us do and they make
us yell and they make us scream and they
heard our voices
and i was like there's a very very
fundamental critical component to this
argument
and that is nobody knows
your limitations better than you it is
incumbent upon me to go hey guys just to
let you know
i know fred tatushra just left and that
that guy
is just like bananas good at what he
does
um i can't do that and so
don't expect me to do that and don't
audition for a role that you
for for uh something that is not
sustainable if you can't continue to do
that and you're trying to impress people
that just put that that creates problems
for mike bithell um
so only do something you can do
you know what i mean so and the other
thing i know exactly what i'm saying
about the boss working hard and leading
it thing is
my biggest issue with the idea that a
boss would be like well i'm working hard
i just want you to work as hard as me is
that i feel like that discounts
anyone who might have any issue that is
outside of their control people with
major anxiety people but depression
can't necessarily work
the same way that a fully able-bodied
boss can also
work your eyes off for me but work your
also for me
and have eight hours sleep and see your
family after you know
i can't make 50 pounds lighter i can't
but what i can do is make sure that
you're lifting properly
and that i'm doing everything i can to
make you do that job safely
but if if i come to you
what mike was talking about before which
is so brilliant is like it's incumbent
upon mike as
the owner of the company to go how are
you doing checking it it's incumbent
upon the employee
to also go i'm not good man so if mike
is doing
that also that then you can punt that
back to mike just to make sure that the
employee
has the freedom to do that like that
they are told yeah at the beginning
you know it's not just
mike asking which is the other big part
of that specifically with with
with a lot of folks like just making
sure that if they're not comfortable
coming to me with a problem because
you've got to remember like i've been
around long enough that a lot of the
people who
work for me played thomas was alone when
they were kids
so there's a very different kind of
relationship in terms of
what we can talk about so we have other
people that they can talk to and you
know they don't have to come to me with
their problems which is
which is good for them because that
takes off because you're right like if
you don't
seem like someone who's who's open to
hearing those problems you're not going
to hear them
um so yeah you have a lot of being a
good manager is knowing
who who your team members really are and
what they
individually need it's like a very big
part of that i think something that troy
is exposing here is also
one of the whenever uh
young composers like right out of school
ask for advice
the thing i've kind of landed on after
answering that
a bunch of times over the years is that
i encourage you
when you're like doing the composer
equivalent of auditioning for a job or
even if it's just the meeting
i always say i encourage you to be as
uncompromisingly
you as you can be to the point of being
explicitly divisive because
like when troy says director number one
says i'm gonna be exhausted you're gonna
be exhausted and you're gonna keep up
and director number two says look we're
going to have
check-in meetings no you're going to
keep up though i need you to keep the
station you know like yeah please do
that's all that i ask of you
fair enough i stand corrected but the
point is
some directors are going to have a very
strong
uh you know kind of it's a
mischaracterization but like this iron
fist style leadership like that
and then others are going to be very
very you know compassionate and
and bethelian uh in their uh
uh their approach and would never uh and
would never say a thing like that
um i do i do not consent to that
i want so many t-shirts i'm caricature
i'm caricaturing
just to make a point my point is when
troy said
it's on you to audition sort of knowing
your limits and whatnot i think that the
the nuance to tug out of that statement
is like if i'm a composer
and i'm sitting down with a game
director or film director
and we're having that initial
conversation and there are real
personality or management
uh mismatches the key is for me to be as
unapologetically myself as possible and
and hope that it brings that out
from them as well and we will very
quickly discover
this isn't going to work and thank god
we're finding it out today and not six
weeks from now after the ink is dry on
the contract and
we're already in a situation where
changing directions is a [ __ ] storm and
so whenever i tell
young composers be divisive i recognize
all your survival instincts of well i
have to build a career i need items on
my resume other they're going to be
fighting against that because you're
going to be this people pleaser who just
wants the job at all costs
but the truth is there are jobs that you
don't want and it's really great to
discover that before you get them
yeah well said
all right i mean there's love i love
this all right wrap it up elana
went very far from nintendo leaks to
like management styles now
i feel like there's been a lot of good
advice in here i'm very appreciative of
all your perspectives
but i guess this is what happens when we
don't have a heart out
could have kept going it's it's a whole
mess and and no internet
and a weird 90s like yeah that's true
i'm making it work troy
i'm in like a new radicals video right
or jamiroquai
i actually kind of like it you should
have used it more you should have used
the no player
nope yeah i especially like it if you
get a text or something and it's like
yeah this is right now i started getting
these notifications like i don't need to
know what my nana
is doing right now or my ring doorbell
or whatever
all right send us home i thought you
meant your grandma i was like you
probably would want to know what she's
up to
uh and in and to put this in the
weirdest uh tangential button
i'm i'm very happy to report um we have
been
slowly over several weeks we have a
squirrel picnic table
that attaches to a fence and it's right
outside of our kitchen window so we can
see every morning
and there's this one dude that got just
jacked up probably by a coyote or
or a possum or something um but he was
super ragged and he ended up looking
like
um splinter from teenage mutant ninja
turtles so we call him splinter
um and i saw him this morning and he he
was looking rough like we were like
he's not long for this world and we saw
splinter this morning
and he came to the bowl and he just
looked at the bowl and saw me in the
kitchen kind of looked up at me and i
was like all right
we go get some almonds and so i brought
him some almonds and so splinter is
doing
much much better like honestly
thank you for sharing okay i'm very
happy to hear about split out i would
like regular updates unless he dies in
which case i don't
i'm worried it's going to go dark that's
my fear i don't know how invested i want
to get
only tell me if it's good otherwise i
would like to forget about it
mike is afraid to bond with splinter
splinter
they can't hurt splinter anymore okay
no splinter's doing great good stuff uh
hope everyone else is doing great
we will see you all next week bye bye
that is the core oh did i cut up oh no
i can still hear you hold on i can still
hear you guys if you can hear me
you gotta be [ __ ] me hold on i'm
still here
i'm still rolling which is the beauty of
this hello internet
this is troy baker what you're
experiencing now is known as a technical
difficulty
but the beauty is i'm always rolling
and this is actually kind of part and
parcel to the whole conversation
i have the right if i want to to stop
recording and you would never hear this
conversation
or alana of course is the host of this
could also
not ever release this the question is
will she will she
will sure well sure boulevard i wonder
if we can get any of this
i wonder if somehow decades later
this will be released on the internet
and i'll be like oh no
those were my private thoughts i should
never have done that